a estas alturas hemos trabajado bastante
viendo cómo se asumen restan multiplican
las matrices y hemos trabajado para
sacar la inversa de una matriz y el
determinante y hasta ahorita vamos a ver
para qué sirven esas matrices ahora
siempre hay que recordar que esto de las
matrices nada más una forma de arreglar
números de retener la información
necesitar ya y tal vez de esa forma de
expresar información de una forma más
sencilla pero bueno en este vídeo vamos
a ver un ejemplo de cuando son súper
útiles las matrices y bueno todas esas
reglas que hemos visto acerca de por
ejemplo cómo se multiplican las matrices
pues todas esas reglas fueron creadas
por los humanos para hacer las cosas más
sencillas y para que realmente funcione
todo esto de las matrices ok no hay nada
en el mundo en la naturaleza que nos
diga las matrices se tienen que
multiplicar de esta forma todo eso lo
inventamos nosotros los humanos y bueno
espero que conforme vayamos viendo
ejemplos de cómo se aplican las matrices
quedando claro lo útiles que son estas
matrices y por qué escogimos estas
reglas para la multiplicación de
matrices y para el resto de las cosas ok
entonces pues vamos a nuestro ejemplo
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es resolver
un sistema de ecuaciones entonces
tenemos nuestro sistema de cuestiones
van a ser dos ecuaciones ahorita los
pongo y pues estas ecuaciones
representan dos líneas rectas y lo que
nosotros estamos buscando es la
intersección de esas dos líneas rectas
ok entonces vamos a poner la ecuación 3x
+ 2 y igual a 7 y la otra ecuación va a
ser menos 6x
6 igualdad de gemelos chico porque
queremos poner aquí un número que haga
las cosas más sencillas si no nos va a
quedar todo a escribir oso ok pues voy a
poner aquí un 6 entonces tenemos aquí
nuestros ejes muy bien el eje de las
equis y el eje de las yes y pues esta
ecuación cuando la crema gráfica se
convierte en la ecuación pues pasamos
esto del otro lado del igual y dividimos
entre dos entonces nos queda ye igual a
siete medios y luego como estamos
pasando esto del otro lado del igual en
realidad tenemos que restar 3x de los
dos lados y nos queda menos
es x pero estamos dividiendo entre 2
para que nos quede la bolita de aquí nos
queda menos tres medios de x así es que
pues siete medios es un poquito más
arriba que 3 se vamos a poner lo que por
aquí y tenemos menos x entonces nuestra
recta va a estar un poquito más
inclinada que menos x más siete medios y
de este lado también queremos despejar
la aie osea que aquí nos queda todo lo
vamos a dividir entre 6 y nos queda ye
igual a 6 entre 61 y luego este menos 6x
lo pasamos del otro lado y nos queda más
6 x entre 6 o sea más x así es que por
acá está un puntito por el que pasa la
recta y tiene exactamente la misma
pendiente que x
si es que
la recta pasa más o menos por acá y lo
que queremos saber es cuál es este
puntito de la intersección de estas dos
rectas ok entonces como le hacíamos
normalmente es tomar estas dos
ecuaciones y resolver directamente el
sistema pero nosotros vamos a usar
matrices para resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones y bueno cuando resolvemos
este sistema de ecuaciones básicamente
lo que estamos haciendo es encontrar
cuál es el punto de intersección ok
porque esta línea verde lo que
representa son todos los puntitos todas
las coordenadas x
que satisfacen esta ecuación y de la
misma forma esta línea recta morada
representa todos los números x
ordenados 1 es x del otro o sea tenemos
un vector aquí que satisfacen esta
segunda ecuación entonces a la hora de
resolver este sistema de ecuaciones y
encontrar los puntitos x con mayer que
satisfacen las dos ecuaciones
estamos encontrando es justo el punto de
intersección de estas dos líneas porque
este punto está en esta recta y por lo
tanto satisface esta ecuación y además
está en esta recta y por lo tanto
satisface esta otra ecuación y bueno
seguro en algún momento ya has visto
métodos para resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones algo así como el método gauss
jordán para sistemas de ecuaciones y
para resolverlo pues teníamos que hacer
algo así como multiplicar toda la
ecuación por un escalar y restarle la
otra ecuación o cosas por el estilo
hasta llegar a que x tiene que ser igual
a tal valor y ya tiene que ser igual a
tal valor pero nosotros lo que vamos a
hacer es resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones utilizando matrices entonces
vamos a ver cómo se ve estas ecuaciones
en el mundo de la matrix matriz en
inglés se escribe como matrix igual que
la película entonces nuestra forma de
representar este sistema de ecuaciones
en forma de matrices
y bueno más tarde nos vamos a detener a
ver que realmente esta representación si
defines las matrices y la multiplicación
entre matrices como lo hemos hecho esta
nueva representación que te voy a
enseñar en unos segundos realmente
representa el mismo problema que este
problema de resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones ok entonces vamos a poner
aquí la matriz 3 menos 6 2
y vamos a hacer que esta matriz se esté
multiplicando por el vector columna x
como ya que hay todos los vectores
columna como este también son matrices y
vamos a decir que esa multiplicación de
estas dos matrices tiene que ser
exactamente igual al vector columna 7
676 ok
aquí lo que hice fue tal cual tomar este
coeficiente y ponerlo acá tomar este
coeficiente y ponerlo acá ósea tomar los
coeficientes de la variable xy ponerlos
en esta columna y luego tomar los
coeficientes de la variable y y ponerlos
en esta columna y al final poner estas
cosas que están del lado derecho del
igual aquí así es que si quieres puedes
ponerle ahorita pausa y hacer esta
multiplicación de matrices y ver que
realmente realmente este problema de
encontrar este vector xy es equivalente
al problema de encontrar xy que
satisfagan estas dos ecuaciones ya lo
resolví este bueno en caso de que no lo
hayas hecho ahorita vamos a hacerlo con
todo detalle así es que bueno para hacer
la multiplicación de esta matriz por
esta otra matriz lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es multiplicar esta fila
por esta columna gay y de eso lo que nos
queda es tres por equis eso es 3x y
después tenemos que sumarle a 2 por jeff
dos porsche porque esta es la forma en
la que se multiplican las matrices y esa
es nada más la primera entrada de arriba
y hasta la izquierda ahora lo siguiente
que tenemos que hacer es tomar la
segunda fila o sea esta fila y
multiplicarla por este vector y lo que
nos va a dar es otra entrada por acá ok
y esa entrada es igual a menos 6 por x
menos 6 por x más
6 por james 6 por g
y este es el resultado de multiplicar
estas dos matrices todo esto es la
primera entrada y todo esto es la
segunda entrada y este vector tiene que
ser exactamente igual a este otro vector
y para que dos vectores sean iguales
tienen que ser iguales entrada por
entrada o sea esta entrada tiene que ser
igual a 7 johnson johnson así es que
tiene que satisfacerse la primera
ecuación y esta otra entrada tiene que
ser igual a esta entrada
así es que se tiene que satisfacer la
segunda ecuación también aunque entonces
nuestro problema se reduce a encontrar
xy ya tales que al multiplicarse por
esta matriz nos dé este vector
bien y cómo resolvemos esto de esta
matriz de aquí le vamos a llamar la
matriz para hacerlo todo más sencillo y
vamos a ponerle a mayúscula porque todas
las matrices que son matrices y no
vectores siempre las escribimos con
letras mayúsculas bueno no siempre pero
la mayoría de las veces y a este vector
que es nuestro vector que queremos
encontrar que todavía no sabemos quién
es pues vamos a llamarle el vector x
esta es una muy mala anotación porque
aquí también tenemos un equis pero sabes
que ya mejor vamos a ponerle una barra
de vector encima y bueno generalmente en
todos los libros van a encontrar que los
vectores están como que rellenitos son
más anchos pero creo que a mí se me va a
complicar mucho estamos haciendo anchos
entonces los voy a dejar flaquitos pero
con su barra encima y a este otro vector
pues vamos a llamarle el vector b porque
si le llaman los libros y también le
podemos poner su barra entonces aquí
esta ecuación de matrices lo que nos
dice es que a por x es igual a el vector
b y voy
al menos cuando tenemos ecuaciones
lineales por ejemplo cuando tenemos
ecuaciones de la forma ad x igual a b
pues para resolverlo lo que hacemos
generalmente es multiplicar por 1 entre
a de los dos lados del igual no que a
veces hasta les llamamos passarella del
otro lado del igual despejarlo pero
formalmente lo que estamos haciendo es
multiplicar por 1 / a
por equis y eso es igual a 1 / a
siempre que sea distinto de cero claro y
entonces este una entrega se cancela con
este a y nos queda que x es igual a 1
entre a por ver muy bien nosotros vamos
a tratar de hacer lo mismo con estas
ecuaciones pero hay que tener mucho
cuidado porque aquí estas ecuaciones son
de matrices y vectores entonces por
ejemplo cosas como la conmuta actividad
o sea que por ejemplo aquí pasaremos
este 1 entrega del otro lado debe eso en
los reales y en muchas ecuaciones
lineales si se vale pero como estas son
matrices a por b es muy distinto que ve
por a ok bueno en algunos casos si son
iguales pero en la mayoría de los casos
si multiplicas a una matriz por la
izquierda de otra matriz es muy distinto
a si inviertes el orden de los factores
que están multiplicando ok entonces
tenemos que tener mucho cuidado con este
tipo de cosas además de que no todas las
matrices tienen lo equivalente a
/ a y bueno a ver qué es lo equivalente
a 1 / a en el mundo de las matrices pues
bueno aquí de una vez lo podemos ver no
o sea 1 entre a le podemos llamar la
inversa de a aquí pudimos haber escrito
a la menos uno o sea inversa de a de los
dos lados del igual bueno el chiste es
que vamos a encontrar la inversa de la
matriz a y la vamos a multiplicar del
lado izquierdo de los dos lados del
igual ok entonces vamos a encontrar a la
menos uno y lo vamos a multiplicar por a
por x vector y esto va a ser igual a a
inverso multiplicando del lado izquierdo
a el vector b y entonces a inversa por a
lo que nos va a dar es la matriz
identidad
y esta va a estar multiplicando a equis
y eso va a ser igual a a moverse por el
vector b pero bueno si un vector está
multiplicando a la matriz identidad esa
multiplicación va a ser exactamente
igual al mismo vector ok entonces la
matriz identidad por x es simplemente
igual a equis y eso pues es igual a la
inversa por b bien vamos a borrar esto
entonces cada que tengas tu sistema de
ecuaciones inscrito en esta forma con
matrices y vectores
si conoces ya la inversa de esta matriz
entonces para encontrar la solución
simplemente tienes que multiplicar este
vector por la inversa de esta matriz ok
bien entonces bueno tal vez tú me
podrías decir oye sal pero es que a mí
me parece que todo esto es demasiado
relajo y demasiado complicado para
resolver un sistema de ecuaciones con
dos ecuaciones y dos variables
desconocidas y bueno tal vez en un
sistema de dos por dos ok tienen razón
es más sencillo y directo hacerlo de la
forma en la que ya sabes hacerlo
simplemente las ecuaciones pero si
tienes un sistema de ecuaciones más
grande entonces tal vez esta forma puede
estar más sencilla está todo más
acomodado y además nada más tienes que
encontrar la inversa de esta matriz y
multiplicar la por este vector y listo
ya está la solución aunque bueno eso de
encontrar las inversas de estas matrices
como son matrices muy grandes también se
vuelve muy complicado entonces bueno
pero cuando si es un hecho que es súper
súper súper útil esta representación en
forma de matrices de este sistema de
ecuaciones es cuando por ejemplo estos
valores van cambiando entonces tú me
dices ahorita es 7 y 6 pero mañana te lo
voy a pedir con 8 y 9 o 15 o 14 o el
número que se te ocurra entonces estos
vectores van cambiando y ahí si es
muchísimo más útil en contra la inversa
de esta matriz y cada que te cambian
este vector multiplicar esa inversa por
este vector y entonces te cambian a cómo
te cambien este vector ya tienes más del
90% del
georgia resuelta o sea porque lo
realmente complicado es encontrar la
inversa de esta matriz pero bueno espero
que quede claro que esta ecuación de
matrices representa exactamente lo mismo
que este sistema de dos ecuaciones bueno
ahora sí ya vamos a resolver este
sistema no que entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es encontrar la inversa de a y
pues la inversa de a es igual a 1 entre
el determinante de la matriz a por la
matriz adjunta de a ok entonces uno
entre el determinante de a eso es uno
entre el determinante de a es éste por
este menos éste por este rey 3 por 6 18
10 y 8 menos 2 por menos 6 menos 12
menos 12 y menos por menos da más o sean
nos queda 18 más 12 esos son 30
todos estos son 30 y aquí la matriz
adjunta
se acuerdan de la matriz adjunta a la
matriz adjunta lo que tenemos que hacer
es cambiar esta entrada por esta entrada
aunque los cambiamos de lugar o sea que
aquí tenemos un 6 y aquí tenemos un 3 y
estas dos entradas las multiplicamos por
menos 1 entonces menos 6 por menos 1 nos
queda 6 aquí tenemos un 6 y 2 por menos
1 nos queda menos 2 menos dos a ver
vamos a escribir esto bien y podríamos
tomar este 1 entre 30 y meterlo dentro
de la matriz y nos quedaría 6 entre 30 o
sea un quinto y menos 2 entre 30 o sea
menos un 15 ago y así pero también lo
podemos dejar afuera lo podemos dejar
así en este caso creo que queda más
simple si lo dejamos de esta forma
aunque entonces ya tenemos la inversa de
la matriz ósea ya tenemos este
y equis o sea lo que estamos buscando
este vector que estamos buscando es
igual a la inversa de la matriz
multiplicada por el vector b que es este
vector o sea estos dos números entonces
x que también lo podemos escribir como
ya hemos visto como x h esto es igual a
la matriz inversa o sea 1 entre 30 por
la matriz
- 23
por estos dos números por este vector
que es el vector b o sea por el vector 7
este es nuestro resultado éste es el
vector que estamos buscando que es la
intersección de estas dos líneas
entonces aquí tenemos que 1 entre 30 por
esta fila por esta columna en el primer
lugar de por acá o sea 7 por 6 42 que
iba a ver una entrada larga por acá pero
son 42 más menos 2 por 6 2 por 6 son 12
2 por 6 son 12 o sea que tenemos menos
12 y ahora vamos a multiplicar la
segunda fila por esta columna o sea 6
por 742 más 3 por 6 18 10 y 8 entonces
tenemos que x es igual a 42 menos 12 eso
es 30
30 por aquí 42 18 esos son 60
y por aquí tenemos que poner el 1 entre
31 entre 30 y ahora si podemos meter
este escalar dentro del vector y lo que
nos queda es 30 entre 30 eso es un 11 y
60 entre 30 esto es 12 entonces lo que
tenemos es que el vector x ya tiene que
ser exactamente igual al vector 12 ok
entonces x tiene que ser igual a 1 y ya
tengo que ser igualados y el vector 12
es el vector que vamos a dibujarlo este
es un 1 y este es un 2 manu el dibujo no
nos quedó exacto pero este es nuestro
resultado esta es la intersección el
vector 1,2 este vector es la
intersección de estas dos rectas y si
sustituimos x igual a 1 y la 2 en estas
ecuaciones vamos a ver que realmente x
igual a 1 y la 2 resuelve en el sistema
de ecuaciones
bueno pareció que esto fue muy largo que
realmente hicimos mucho trabajo pero
recuerda que todo esto y la mayor parte
de este vídeo se trata de ver que
realmente este sistema de ecuaciones era
equivalente a encontrar este vector
columna pero si lo resuelves
directamente o sea si tomas este sistema
de ecuaciones les sacas la matriz
tomando los coeficientes nada más en
cuenta es la matriz inversa y la
multiplicas por este otro vector
entonces vas a ver que es súper rápido y
super directo bueno en el próximo vídeo
lo que vamos a hacer es esto mismo pero
para otro problema para que veas que
realmente son muy útiles estas matrices
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo que
te diviertas mucho